on the Grand Union canal in London a  strange sculpture is coming to life  well this is awesome so how is this  bridge going from this to this the  bridge is made up from eight trapezoidal  sections each trapezoidal section has  two Pistons one on either side of the  walkway the powerful Pistons emerge from  hydraulic cylinders which are filled  with an incompressible fluid passing  through tubes ultimately powered by a  pump when the bridge is in its down  position and the hydraulic Pistons are  activated the handrails are pushed  towards each other which causes the  bridge to fold up into its closed  position  when it opens the hydraulic Pistons  activate this pushes the sections apart  and it becomes a working bridge again  the bridges strength has not been  compromised by this design amazingly  when this bridge rolls out and locks  into place it can support about 20,000  pounds  that's 9,000 kilograms or a hundred  Hakeem's which is more than enough for  anyone  [Music]